Hallo Wolfgang. Hallo Stefan, wir sind hier in der Garderobe und gleich geht's
los, gleich beginnt die große Show.
Richtig. Bist du schon aufgeregt? Ja, wir müssen vor allem, ich muss kurz erstaunen,
in Tönen darbieten, was du trägst. Ich sag mal, wow!
Leuchtet das von selber? Es glitzert sehr, aber ich dachte, es könnte doch zu
so einem festlichen Anlass kurz vor Weihnachten genau der richtige Anzug sein.
Absolut. Wenn einer Schwiegersohn ist, dann dieser Wolfgang M. Schmidt.
Wer nicht hier gewesen ist heute, hat die Show verpasst. Aber wir liefern euch ein Audio.
Genau, wir liefern ein Audio und bei Instagram wird man wahrscheinlich auch
dann Fotos von uns sehen können.
Wir haben vieles vor in diesem Live-Salon. Wir sprechen über China kurz.
Dann sprechen wir länger über, ja, wie würdest du es bezeichnen?
Du hast eine richtige PowerPoint vorbereitet. Also das soll aber die,
die uns nur hören, nicht davon abhalten, das sich zu Gemüte zu führen.
Die TikTok-Trends sind dann am besten, wenn sie auf einen Begriff runterbrechbar
sind. Und das ist hier das Manifestieren.
Da wir diese Regierung nicht loskriegen, wünschen wir uns eine bessere und gucken
mal, was das nächste Jahr so bringt.
Okay, und das hat dann auch alles mit Chat-GPT irgendwie zu tun?
Ja, Chat-GPT, generative Mechanismen für Textproduktion, ist natürlich das Manifestieren
schlechthin. Wir denken uns eine Wirklichkeit aus, prompten und dann hoffen
wir mal, dass es gut geht.
Und ich wollte wissen, wie tickt denn eigentlich Deutschland?
Das fragt man ja sich hin und wieder und dann gibt es ja verschiedene Interpretationsansätze.
Du sprichst ja davon der alten Republik.
Wir können ja so sagen, wie tickt Deutschland? Man könnte Tagesschau gucken,
den Spiegel lesen, mal über die Straße gehen, mal einkaufen gehen.
Was ist deine Einflugschneise zur Frage, wie tickt Deutschland?
Man sieht sich einfach mal die Show an, die am meisten geguckt wird und noch
hundertmal wiederholt wird, nämlich das Adventsfest der Tausend Lichter mit Florian Silbereisen.
Aber wir werden jetzt keine Musik hier spielen, sondern wir werden uns anhören,
was wird da eigentlich geredet.
Und auf Grundlage dieser doch eigenartigen Dialoge, die da stattfinden,
versuchen wir uns an einer Gegenwartsanalyse.
Das versprechen wir also zumindest. Das zeigt Diagnostik nie besser.
Ich habe gestern noch das André Rieu Weihnachtskonzert geguckt.
Er hat es ja selber auf seinen YouTube-Kanal hochgeladen. Nach einer Woche eine
Million Views, fand ich beeindruckend.
Da wird auch extrem viel geredet. Das ist fast wie Bono auf der Bühne.
Nach jedem Lied wird genauso lange noch mal getextet.
Es scheint Textbedarf zu geben. Darauf kommen wir heute häufiger zu sprechen.
In der Tat. Und wir wollen aber, bevor wir jetzt gleich rausgehen,
noch kurz ankündigen, was wir im Januarsalon lesen.
Wir haben uns da nämlich ein Buch rausgesucht, das schon im Ausland für Furore gesorgt hat.
Es stammt von der Journalistin Gaia Vins.
Es heißt, das nomadische Jahrhundert, wie die Klimamigration unsere Welt verändern
wird, ist bei Pipa erschienen.
Und wir haben schon über das Buch von Parakena sehr ausführlich gesprochen und
haben gesagt, ja, MOVE, das ist ein interessanter neuer Ansatz,
um über Migrationspolitik nachzudenken.
Und dies scheint wieder ein solches Buch zu sein, das grundlegend einen anderen
Blick ermöglicht auf Migration.
Und das ist das große Thema. Wir haben jetzt gerade diesen Asylkompromiss verabschiedet in der EU.
Und deshalb müssen wir dieses Thema aufgreifen. Und ich glaube,
das wird ein Buch sein, das viele starke Thesen präsentiert.
Und darüber wird dann zu reden sein.
Das geht im Salon. Ihr kennt die Einflugschneisen.
Steady. Man geht zu Steady. Sucht dort Podcasts oder geht darüber über neue20er.de.
Folgt dem goldenen Button. Wir bevorzugen Steady, aber es gäbe auch der direkte
Weg Apple Podcast, für die, die über Apple Podcast hören.
Und Patreon natürlich, für die, die schon einen Patreon-Account haben.
Ansonsten, falls ihr hier überlegt, selber in den Salon zu kommen oder das zu
verschenken, es ist ja jetzt Dezember und Weihnachten, ihr könnt auch wieder
die Geschenkeoption ziehen.
Special Feature läuft nach einem Jahr aus.
Also ihr kauft einfach für ein Jahr Salon für eure Liebsten,
verschenkt das, Das müsst nicht jeder darüber nachdenken, denn nach einem Jahr
ist es automatisch beendet.
Ja, und vielleicht braucht da der Onkel, die Tante eine kleine Florian-Silber-Eisen-Analyse.
Das alles werden wir heute liefern.
Aber jetzt genug geredet, wir müssen raus auf die Bühne. So ist es. Bis gleich.
Guten Abend. So, ihr wisst alle, wo ihr seid. Wir machen das ja nicht zum ersten
Mal. Ihr wisst auch, wer wir sind.
Wir wissen nachher bestimmt, wer ihr seid. Deswegen lasst uns eine kleine Premiere feiern.
Das ist für den heutigen Abend der Anzug von Wolfgang M. Schmidt.
Vielen Dank.
Ich hoffe, dass ich gleich mit meinem vielen Gerede nicht allzu sehr vom Anzug
ablenke, aber gehen wir mal in den Abend.
Musik.